all right so
it's so it's 11 a.m here in new haven uh
in connecticut i'd like to welcome you
all to yale to this very special event a
webinar between two to distinguished
alums of the department
i'm actually sitting right in front of
the department of economics where we
have not been located for the past year
during the zoom
during the zoom era but it's a beautiful
spot
as the governor knows he's and his todd
neat knows
he's there is a beautiful spot and i i
hope
i know some of you are considering
coming to yale perhaps as part of our
dide program and i hope that
you can experience this spot for
yourselves uh
next year so let me just say that what
we're here for today is to celebrate
um the the long history of the
yale ide program which really was the
precursor
is it was a it preceded the creation of
the economic growth center
both of which have a very long and
storied history here
in the department um and i think because
of these two institutions the
the department over the last 50 to 60
years really
65 years has grown into one of the
world's centers for development
economics
and not only doing research but doing
policy
you know asking the biggest questions
and trying to to change the world really
and answering those policy questions
how do we how do we develop um so we
have a long and storied uh
long story tradition and it's a central
part of the uh the identity of
the economics department uh it actually
goes back to i guess lloyd reynolds i
read
a history that uh michael buser who's
the current uh
director of the master's program wrote
and so i read some of that in preparing
for this uh talk i learned some things
so that
history goes back to lloyd reynolds who
was chair of the department before me
i'm the current
the current chair by the way of the
department uh it goes back to uh the 50s
and then he brought in someone named
robert triffin who created the
international and foreign economic
administration program
uh which bob evanson then in the 60s
renamed to the current
uh international development economics
program
so we have a lot a long and storied
history um
and where we today we have two of our
illustrious graduate programs one
of either either the yale economics
program or the id program
or both so we have here governor
patrick jerobi i hope i'm pronouncing
that roughly correctly because i read
about it on the web
so thank you very much uh who has
graciously
uh uh decided to agree to join us today
uh he received his phd from yale in 1990
1993 if i'm right and um
has worked in the international economic
policy committee for a long time the imf
and elsewhere
and is now the governor of the central
bank of kenya and i should say that
we have a long tradition of central
bankers coming from the
from the yale economics program of
course there's janet yellen who's now
the secretary of the treasury who has
got her phd in 71.
urgent patel who won the wilbur cross
medal last year
a very prestigious medal that we give to
our illustrious grads from yale
has received his phd in 1990 and just
learned today that the governor of the
bank of thailand is also a yale phd in
1994.
i won't try to pronounce his name today
i didn't practice that one
um so and then uh todd
suri is also here she is not only a yale
phd but
a graduate one of our luster's graduates
of the master's program in
ide and many of our graduates have gone
on to great things in policy making
uh and academia and tom need is um you
know one of the role models i think for
many people
she's worked in many aspects of research
uh
and and policy making as a professor at
the sloan school of management
but also uh as a you know as a very
active member of the uh
of jay pal uh the poverty action lab at
mit
so we're very happy to welcome her here
too um
so with those words um let me just say
i'm looking forward to today's
discussion on
fintech which is a very important area
that tony doesn't work
hard on i know um
especially so i i will pass it over to
you and i look forward to our discussion
great thanks tony i really appreciate it
and thanks for the kind
words um yeah we do have a storied
history of central bankers
um which is interesting uh maybe more to
come
so uh thanks for everyone who's here and
who's attending
uh the way we decided to run this event
is just have a conversation
uh governor jorge it's a pleasure to
have you here kuribusana
as we would say and um
i'm gonna have a conversation with the
governor and then we'll try and open up
to q a
the way the q a will work for folks
please type in your questions into the q
a and zoom and i'll moderate and read
them out as we go
and you can upvote the q a in the in the
uh in the q a function of zoom
so please use that if you have questions
um
and i think we're off to the races
governor welcome again thank you for
being here on behalf of yale on behalf
of all of us
it's really nice to start this series of
celebrating both the growth center and
the ide program
at yale um you know sort of kicking off
their celebrations with this event and
we're really glad you can be here so
welcome
thank you yeah great um
so the let me start early days and ask
you a bit about kind of
your career path and how you ended up at
central bank governor in kenya
and maybe you can tell us a bit about
that journey and and how you got there
thank you ternet and uh first i would
like to
thank uh tony and everyone else in my
alma mate
um for the invite um and
i'm definitely delighted to be back uh
though virtually
and uh thanks tony for that background
uh on your zoom
uh portal um and uh
really my journey started way back um
when well as an economist really
when i did my uh my undergraduate and
masters in the university of nairobi
i was quite interested in economics
more so that i can change the world not
so much in this sort of
modern way but uh maybe changing the
lives of people
um in particular ways so in any event i
did that and then of course
uh came to yale which was a very
exciting time
we can talk a bit more about that
and after doing my phd i went back to
nairobi
and worked in the government ministry of
finance
and then eventually decided that uh i
had seen enough of the ministry and i
got a job at the imf
in uh from 1995 where i was for 20 years
that was very exciting i mean really
that is where
i learned to become a real i mean i was
nurtured in a sense
um and improving my skills etc
20 years of that but
i was happy with what i was doing
and even career-wise etc and that's when
this job came up
uh being uh central bank the job of the
central bank governor
i wasn't very interested in it at the
beginning because you know i
had everything sort of in front of me
but then i had this nagging problem
which is
maybe i could make a difference at home
in kenya having worked with all sorts of
other countries
maybe i could maybe i wouldn't but i
could never really tell
i could not tell unless i tried so
that's what i did
so i applied and uh here we are
uh five and a half years later
as the governor of the central bank of
kenya
great thank you um yes we'll talk more
about
you being governor in a little bit um
but you know let me ask a little bit
about the imf
and the transition from the imf to being
central bank governor to moving back
home
um you know i i spent a lot of time at
home but i haven't quite
moved back home yet like you so how is
that transition
and you know how has it been over the
last few years
yeah firstly i mean i did enjoy my time
at the imf it was great
i was challenged as an economist and
really honed my skills as an economist
the transition from sort of classroom
paradigms to
sort of actual policy and discussion
with
authorities and governments across
geographies
etc i mean that i think was very good
uh training ground and i learned a lot
um
and really got that sort of um instinct
of where things are etc so that was very
exciting of course we have
very interesting people that were
interested that
are still interested in development
economics generally
but i think uh policy was obviously very
important one of the things that i
learned there of course was
a phrase that one of the gov wire i
guess one of somebody told me
which is no one really no one cares
what you know until they know how much
you care
and that i think is something that has
stayed with me all this
time you know all this many years but
the transition
coming back home of course you're coming
back home from uh
let's say an environment where
everything is all clear you know
systems work um you know
to earn to a system where obviously your
things are not working very well um
but uh so there was a bit of a
transition and then realizing that
it is you you know if you don't do if
you don't make policy you don't push
it won't get done of course the other
things that were really surprising
like of course i always knew about kenya
being
at the forefront of uh digital um
money etc etc but coming back home and
realizing that
you know to this day i've never uh done
an over-the-counter transaction
you know everything for me is digital um
yeah okay there's an occasional check
that i have to write but uh beyond that
um so i think it was kind of exciting in
some ways but also quite challenging in
others
of course you don't have much time to
worry about your own personal things
you know it's all the issues in front of
you but it's been quite challenging and
i have enjoyed the challenge
yeah and you get to see family all the
time absolutely i like differently
yeah than washington i think then also
new haven so
oh that's better way better
yes one of the things i miss most the
weather sadly
yeah absolutely um yeah i think you know
it's interesting um the digital stuff
it's
it's different seeing it from afar and
then like being
you know sort of in person realizing
just how salient
and broad it is and how much it's sort
of pervasive and a pervasive part of
life
uh around around not just nairobi but
all over
um you know so let's talk about that
piece a little
um what do you why do you think it's
been so successful and what do you
attribute that to
is it kind of the regulation side do you
think
there's other pieces of the the success
of this that you
would love to talk about okay um
well you're right technique really kenya
is the
cradle of fintech we could also argue
between ourselves and ethiopians whether
kenya is the cradle of man but that's
that can take us way way into the
evening right i think we'll both say the
same thing it really is yeah absolutely
absolutely two kenyans uh talking about
this
yeah would agree instantly exactly um
so the cradle of fintech and this is
really where it started
um and really uh
that was back in 20 2006
uh that is when well among other things
that's when we had the first iphone but
i think more importantly
that's when um the the product and pesa
came into being actually in 2007
that's when we actually brought it into
into the into the live world as it were
and it has been very very successful i
think there are many ways of measuring
the success of this but i think the
first one i need to point out is
how successful it has been in bringing
us forward
in terms of financial inclusion it was
at uh
26 financial inclusion or 26 percent of
our adults were
included in um
in 2007 and now it is actually 83 plus
percent so it has really helped us lead
from
in terms of financial inclusion those
are those are things that i think you
and i
in a policy environment or class
discussion you think of sort of doubling
financial inclusion you know
to 50 i mean that's huge so
going to 85 percent and it's still
increasing
is something that is obviously
remarkable that's one way of measuring
it
but i think uh your question is uh well
there are some
ways but i'll i'll come to that towards
the end
why was it successful i think first and
foremost because there
was a particular need so there was a
need that it was feeling basically
it came to us through the transfer
payments sort of uh as a payment
platform
so i could send money people there was a
need in the sense that uh
people needed to send their money to
their family back home in the rural
areas and instead of giving it to the
let's say to the bus conductor or using
the postal service and
et cetera et cetera i mean this actually
filled a very urgent and indeed
important need
so and that's really what happened so
when it was devised it was really
devised as a transfer
between p to p as we call it today
between persons
so the need secondly the regulator
looked at it and uh
and actually was innovative meaning
didn't want to throttle the technology
but actually looked at the concerns
like financial stability and other
concerns
security etc and uh allowed the
innovator um to sort of improve so as to
mitigate against those
risks and then allow them in a sort of a
test and learn environment
um to launch the product obviously
knowing or understanding that if there
was a significant problem it would be
pulled off the wall
as it were you know speaking i think
that was uh
something that was that was also
a very important in terms of this so
your question about
regulation there were no regulations at
the time
so actually the regulations came later
in 2013
that's when we put some regulations in
place but there was clear
understanding between the innovator and
ourselves um
about sort of the rules of the game and
how we moved that forward
obviously at the end of the day uh there
was very effective uh
collaboration amongst everyone else the
consumers etc regulators
i mean uh among everyone else who came
into this ecosystem and today now
it is a very elaborate ecosystem that is
not just on the payment side but
uh has grown into a well uh a mature
sort of environment
yeah great thanks so let's talk about
that mature environment you're just
teeing up all my questions governor i
love it
so one of the big pieces that has grown
from it
is kind of these apps or wallets that
allow you to
to borrow right so the most successful
example in kenya
is a digital bank account that the
commercial bank of africa has built
over the rails of mobile money uh it's
called emswari
just just for the audience not for you
governor of course
um you know and so you know that's one
of the most successful
digital lending products and digital
bank accounts what do you see the future
of those sorts of things
uh are there benefits to them are there
risks are you regulating them how do you
think of those sorts of
products over the rails of mobile money
okay
um precisely we do have the rails now
and now what we need to do is to put on
the wagons as it were
and i think one of them is the one that
you mentioned or one set of products are
the ones you mentioned
sort of blending and this is sort of
uh micro lending that's what i guess we
used to call it before
and now on your mobile you can call it
all sorts of other things
um on your mobile device um i think
there's a
there's a great future for them um and
it isn't just
that one world and there are many other
war guns that need to be put in place
as a matter of fact with the rails now
what we need to do is to work
to make sure that the environment
continues to
or the ecosystem continues to mature of
course there are some risks
and i think these are the concerns that
we as a regulator need to
watch out for it's not our job to
innovate in the sense of saying
this is the direction let's say picking
winners in the old-fashioned way
right we do understand that was actually
a bane of
let's say industrial policy in the past
yeah
industrial policy one 1.2 so
not picking winners but actually setting
the rules
so that the innovators can expand as
needed etc
but i think the concerns often are from
our perspective financial stability
and this could be if it is in a lending
environment from
overborrowing uh or of a lending
or for that matter you know the issues
of consumer protection
so costs etc um
and these are things that we need to or
the way the consumers are being dealt
with
so that is something that we as a
regulator need to be
not just conscious of but to monitor and
improve
one of the concerns we have actually is
some so-called uh
well we call them digital well credit
only lenders
that are not regulated by the central
bank or for that matter by anyone else
and unfortunately they've grown like
mushrooms
and also like mushrooms you need to be
careful
which mushrooms you eat others made some
poisonous stuff
and these actually have been a
big concern for the consumers as a
matter of fact in terms of their size
they are less than one percent of uh
credit
um in the system actually they are less
than the smallest bank that we have here
in kenya
and but in terms of the noise from the
consumers
i mean it's huge so we are putting in
place now
some regulations and actually some
there is some regulations a bill a bill
that is in parliament today
that will uh put order in this area but
i think the point to
make is that it is important
to be clear from our perspective
cbks or the central bank's philosophy
with regard to
regulation which is you want to maximize
the
opportunities uh from innovation while
minimizing the risks you know
and the benefits as you say um are huge
i mean i i am uh you see i'm
i was uh one of the first papers i read
about the
impact of em pesos years term meat you
remember that
well you measured the impact of uh
pesos or two percent
two percentage point reduction in
poverty yes i never told you that uh
uh what actually went through my mind at
the
time you see years ago
i wrote i was trying to do a term paper
at yale
of course um and tian srinivasan
was the one it was this class and i
don't remember what it was about but
uh basically uh i was
i guess i was trying we were discussing
um
uh the impact of trade uh yeah the trade
reforms that were there at the time and
tien was an expert on that and how
actually in general equilibrium models
if you try to
measure the impact of a trade reform um
liberalizing trading it's only the
models always give you a very small
estimate somewhere like one percent to
two percent
but we all know that the the advantage
of
uh of uh trade reforms is
much more than two percent and tien told
me
sort of in passing as part of my my
my paper i mean he made the point that
actually the benefits come
from new products
and i remember going away trying to
figure out okay how am i going to model
these new products you know
i don't know even creation destruction
or whatever else it is
but anyway the point i'm making is your
two percent
uh as you mentioned is actually a major
underestimate because you have all these
other things that have mushroomed
mushrooms
meaning the wagons and those have
actually huge benefit as we have
actually seen yeah absolutely governor i
completely agree that's like the pure
rails
on the rails with nothing on the rails
except that
um yeah i will say you know you
mentioned tien i took tian's class
only a few years after your governor but
i did it was like a trade development
class
he was still the same person yeah i
remember him fondly
um so i can imagine him saying just what
you're saying
yeah i think trying to aggregate up all
the bits and pieces will take us
a while as researchers but i think it
also means there's a lot of
interesting open questions to understand
what each of these products does
and how they how you can design them
better how you can build them better
um you know i personally have been a
little
underwhelmed by the innovation because i
feel like there should be more products
right
so i'm hoping there's a lot more coming
and i i like your view of regulation
being
we don't want to restrict innovation we
just want to manage the risks that come
from it
in risk to the financial system that
come from it
but yeah but uh if you just let me say
one thing that just struck me now and
saying that you see um i spend a lot of
time
listening to innovators i mean they come
here and do their dog and pony show and
tell us
uh they show us what they are doing
their widgets and things like that
and you know there are certain things
that strike me first is a lot of them
that are in africa
are still stuck in the payments area
payments payments payments now they all
say that they want to reduce the cost of
payments
but i think they need to expand
and begin to look at other problems um
elsewhere
and also in the financial space as it
were
and uh and i think that is what i would
strongly
encourage the innovators is there any
innovators on the
you know on this webinar um the
in the u.s actually it's not so much in
the payment
space it's more in the capital markets
area you know wealth management etc
that's where there's a lot more
action by fintech etc etc but i think
the
my point here is let the innovators look
at the
at the problems and figure out how to
fix the problem
let them not come with a sort of a
prefixed or you know pre-ordained idea
that
everything is payments because that's
not true i think we need more wagons
elsewhere
yeah i'm in complete agreement sadly i'm
not going to disagree with you governor
there are no controversy here
to a point where we're going to disagree
i'm sure i'm sure
but i agree we agree on everything so
i just gave a spiel on a call this
morning governor where i sort of
gave this example there's not enough
wagons and
wagons that work for seventy percent of
people not five percent of people in the
country right
i think a lot of people get absorbed in
the nairobi
lifestyle kind of that's their view of
the country
and to be honest until i did field work
in kenya i didn't really
appreciate kind of the breath that is
our country so i think that's a piece
where people's use cases often are for a
small group of people
and then the wagon doesn't really take
off right it just doesn't do all that
much
so i would also encourage people to
think about not just wagons but wagons
that work for large truck
large portions of our population not
just a few
awesome so you know we've talked a bit
about this stuff
um what do you see as the future of
fintech so when we think about
innovation where do you see those
the scope for those products what do you
think
that fintech itself can really bring to
the continent
bring to our country okay
um my view is that the future
of fintech in africa is bright i mean
let's begin there
um for many reasons first we
there are many needs right there are
many
uh you can look around and you'll see
many problems that need to be resolved
uh in the financial space we are talking
of course
and uh and i would call this sort of
more generally the democratization of
of uh financial services you and i um
can have a lot of let's say financial
services that available to us
um you can go to you know even wealth
managers or whatever
savings options not everybody in africa
has that as a matter of fact
there's a lot of if we want to move
ahead
in terms of investment savings is a key
driver
but we need to get the savings from
everyone else
so i think there is a lot of need here
secondly you don't have legacy
structures um so you can actually leap
frog
from where we are with very little
in terms of structures to something that
is let's say
designed 21st
technology etc etc
sadly remember 60 percent of our
population in sub-saharan africa
um are youth right um
and that is about a third of our
workforce is below the age of 25.
so you have a lot of let's say the
pyramid
is uh truly a pyramid and a lot of that
a lot of the youth are educated et
cetera et cetera i mean it is it's not
being
a phd sort of person that you need to
that's not education here as a matter of
fact as we have discovered
the kenyan population are very quick
are very technologically savvy um
i have stories about this and i'm sure
we can tell
stories we have more time about you know
meeting people who
are actually doing let's say
things that you and i will kind of uh
not quite
uh get there quickly right um they have
it in their fingertips in terms of using
technology
adopting technology you know our
grandmothers kind of
are very accustomed to technologies that
maybe people in the u.s are not
um i mean we're still having trouble
with our remote
you know tv remote etc right well
actually people here
are very advanced in terms of dealing
with those things
but also as i say um i think people
should begin to
look at i mean some of the things just
as
examples i know a lot of us are stuck
with the technology so the questions i
get uh blockchain you know
dlt you know things like that i think
that's
looking at things the wrong way look at
the problem
what problem are we trying to resolve
and then ask the question
what solution do you need so it's a bit
like writing a thumb paper
you know you don't write the term paper
by first solving the equations or
whatever else it is what is the problem
that you are dealing with what is the
what is the economic problem or the
research problem that you're dealing
with so
it is more than um having said that
uh i i really think um
that applying the let's say all the
ideas that are out there
africa will really leap frog not just on
fintech but in other areas as well
and i think here is where much more
excited because
i mean there's so much that can change
quickly
you know i talked about uh the tripling
uh more than tripling of the financial
inclusion numbers in kenya and actually
elsewhere in africa because of such a
uh sort of transformative
technology i mean you have other things
as well that have changed in that way
i mean in terms of for instance and the
example that i remember is rwanda
rwanda in terms of ease of doing
business in that much maligned
uh let's say uh let's just maybe we
shouldn't talk about each of doing
business anymore
i mean let's get embarrassed as
economists as well but i think the point
is uh
in 2007 there are number one
30-something 135 or thereabouts
and by 2017
they were at number four or five
yeah in terms of doing business and
and you know other things i mean an
example that i also
in my head um is uh you know
in 20 2007 nigeria was the second
largest importer of cement
in the world number one of course is the
us
but then in uh ten years later
a little more than 10 years later
actually they had
they were sufficient self-sufficient
cement and were actually pushing to
export because there has
been such a change in that industry so
i'm just making the point that most of
the things if they are done correctly
can be transformative of course as
development experts
or develop people interested in
development as economists
we ask ourselves is it actually changing
the lives of people
and i think it is i think it is yeah
excellent yeah i think the what problem
you're trying to solve is a big one
uh uh especially when people talk about
blockchain as you said i always push
like
what is it solving that a regular pretty
decent database won't solve for me
right tell me there's value but i think
people
often don't quite get that view of the
world which is
try and figure out the problem you're
trying to solve for at least
you know in my books also not just one
person many people right i want it to be
a reasonably broad problem you're trying
to solve
um yeah i think fintech will be
interesting to watch
over the next couple of decades i think
it will either take off and be great or
kind of we won't have figured out enough
innovation to get as much out of it as
we could and i hope it's the former
um let me go back a little bit and just
uh talk a bit more about
kind of policy making in africa or kenya
more specifically we've known each other
for a few years now governor i
think we met right as you got appointed
if i'm if i remember correctly
and i think it was the museum right i
think that's where we met with the
national museum
absolutely yeah so you know i
i know you've worked extremely hard in
kenya to make our banking system
uh should i say more efficient let's see
more efficient
uh without being explicit um
you know i'd love to hear your
perspective on what you think your
biggest success has been so far
um and and also what you found
hard about your current position wow
and all within uh two minutes no don't
take your time we have time
okay well um you see that
i i'm not sure like at this point you
know one can look back
uh and sort of be comfortable but anyway
let that be um
but if i were to okay fine if uh if i'm
thinking of the most significant things
i think the first one in my mind without
a doubt
would be covet 19 the response to corby
19.
um this has been a very difficult year
very diff for any policy maker anywhere
and for any economist anywhere and the
numbers have been swinging numbers not
so much numbers but the economies have
been swinging
you know huge numbers right i remember
in march last year
i was looking at some of my notes
actually from a year ago
uh because of we are now one year there
right so
and i was looking at some of the
statements that were made by
um the jpoil the
governor at the fed years years fred
and he was saying that uh would have
something like you know
well actually 30 percent right 30
sort of declines um things that
nobody ever thought of you know you're
thinking
huge declines is five percent
it was amazing off the chats um
surviving that
but it isn't just surviving it's
actually figuring out policies
that would maintain and strengthen the
economy
even as the containment measures were
put in place
restrictions on travel close down et
cetera et cetera
i think we have been quite successful
all things considered and we have had
some sort of retrospection
um over the last few weeks and uh in
terms of for instance the
this the way the banks have responded or
responded at the beginning
um we've been quite i think we did
reasonably well on that the decline
actually
um we still haven't seen the first
numbers
in the first print numbers but they
estimate something like one percent
growth
um maybe a little less uh but around
there
um actually i i'm not sure it is just
that but then
let's wait a few weeks and they'll give
us the first numbers
but uh i think i told you this stuff
need the first time
i mean from around february which is
when we began to see this thing coming
the first time i actually slept had
sound sleep throughout the night
was sometime in october all those many
months sort of
you know figuring in a sense being very
very
uh uncomfortable with things etc my mind
not at ease so um so i think
that is number one in terms of what i'm
proud of
and what maybe has been the most
important
um if we had not done what we did i
think we'll be talking a completely
different story
um that's one the second one
is uh maybe what you mentioned but the
way i put it is sort of the
strengthening of the banking sector
uh and i think there has been a lot
there
um first and foremost i would say is the
culture that was pervasive in the
banking sector
a culture that is probably not
consistent with
you know proper pricing and
you know ethical practices etc um
so cleanup of the sector of course that
also meant that we had to
take the hard decision of closing some
banks with close three
and uh and put them in receivership at
one we actually uh put them in um
we in liquidation and the other two are
in receivership
so it has been it was tough obviously
knowing the impact on
uh on the people and until
covey 19 came along these were the
toughest decisions that
i ever did um or we ever did and we
didn't take those decisions slightly
i remember one in particular we were up
48 hours straight uh working on
this thing and that was sort of the
final moments
um after many weeks and a few months
also
you know sort of trying to deal with
those issues so that is one
now of course it isn't enough just to
clean up you need to put it in place
you need to sort of begin a certain new
a new normal as it were
and i think that is what we try to
impact on the
all the actors in the sector
and we want the banking sector to
work with and for kenyans and
actually uh during this covet 19
uh period uh it is because of that
because of that sort of newfound way of
looking at things that we have been able
to uh to do
what we we did um so in that sense the
if well just a thumbnail sketch on this
um it was more important for banks banks
understood
um that it is more important to protect
their balance sheet
as opposed to protecting uh their p l
um so they their profits so
and in a sense that's why they
restructured some of the loans with the
uh with their
borrowers um so as to maintain that
borrowers of course were
uh was selected in the sense that they
were already
i mean they were they had performing
loans
so you're not restructuring you're not
agreeing you're doing
the right thing which is only performing
loans restructuring them to support them
etc so
that is important and of course uh
customer centricity
uh good correct pricing as um
etc etc so that's number two number
three
briefly is strengthening the
this is something that most people have
not seen uh
because it's really fixing the back room
you know things in the back end
um at least sort of strengthening the
financial infrastructure
so the infrastructure itself for
instance
hardening it to be you know again cyber
security
i mean on cyber issues you know added in
it
a lot more um improving for instance the
credit information system
um which we have done significant uh
refresh in that space but also other
things we've improved our
rtgs which is our real-time growth
settlement systems
um and frankly this now is attending
it's at wild standard
and we can now move towards a 24 7
economy
because we have the capacity to do that
um i mean to
to run that in terms of numbers in terms
of all the options that you have
but importantly data i mean if we're in
the 21st century we have to talk later
and so we are doing a lot of work to
make sure that we are we are putting
data together
in a particular way so that we can make
data uh based you know
decisions rather than sort of random
random decisions
you know so there's a also having a
better
central depository system central
security depository system
you know with all these things we will
really be in the 21st century
and at that point we'll be just saying
we are the
um we are an important financial system
it will be
well we are there you know it is nairobi
because everything else is in place
anyway those are the three things i
could probably say great thanks kevin i
appreciate it i'm gonna switch to q a in
a second
um but yeah i think you know it feels
like with all of these improvements now
the innovators are just have no excuse
anymore come play
i think that's what we should say to
innovators is just come play
and nairobi is the greatest city in the
world no exceptions
i think yeah we are not going to argue
we agree entirely yes uh i argue with
lots of people
over nairobi being the best city though
i will say all right i'm going to start
some questions if you don't mind from
the audience
governor i hope that's okay um i'll
start with a question from irene wagaki
irene thanks for being here
she asks fintech credit at the moment is
mostly for consumption smoothing
most smes have to go to banks for
sizable funding
you know i'm sure he's not lending to
smes um
and there's still a lot of consumer
protection issues there how could
do you have a vision for how fintechs
can solve
sme financing issues excellent excellent
excellent irene
um i i think it is this is something
we've been working on
for some time i think we need to dial
back maybe
two years uh it was 29
when uh january of 2019 when we went
out there and began looking at fintechs
not fintechs i'm sorry smes and i toured
the
various places the various markets um
actually i love that i had never
uh since my return i hadn't had that
sort of
freedom to walk um in the
thick of things you know anyway um
but one of the things that came out of
that actually is a product
um that is called stowy and basically
this is an
anytime anywhere financing for
smes and it really
the whole point here is that as an sme
my information in terms of transactions
etc that i do
selling you know buying selling is on my
phone
on my say my my mobile platform
right so that if that information is
gathered and
assessed correctly you can actually
provide a pretty good
sense of credit score there as a matter
of fact i don't remember the numbers now
but
it is better than having a credit
officer in terms of
uh judging the credit worthiness
of somebody using that in information
so this is something that i think we are
well unfortunate recovery 19 came and so
that was tossed out that would
you know was put on let's say on the
shelf you know
on ski on ice or whatever else it is
yeah
but i think now that the economy is uh
beginning to
uh come or is coming back this would be
a central point
now i should hasten to say that smes
they need credit but they need credit
plus and that class element other
elements you know like
maybe being given some sort of
well been trained to do the accounts
better
um or for that matter improving their
skills
i mean one of the ones that we were
thinking of and i saw this
is uh some of the welders you know and
they need to be taught how to do better
welding
um sort of uh joints and things like
that
and uh and basically they can do that in
three hours
um so the bank works with them and they
bring
some sort of uh track on site
um that actually they are taught how to
do well
you know for three hours in the day
there you know and and i think it is
those sort of things innovative ways of
let's say upscaling people's skills
providing them with credit you know one
of the things that
one of the person i remember when i went
on this
whatever it is excursion was a painter
and uh a new you know car painter so he
would sell
paint um to the
people that are painting they repair
your kind and they have to repaint it
right
so his job was to sell his it was all
about
paints and we asked him so what will it
take
for you to move to the next level
and he said well actually all it will
take me
is something like uh one thousand
dollars worth of equipment
which would make him sort of uh
allow him to sort of mix the pains and
therefore have all sorts of colors you
know
um not just have the i don't know the 10
different colors or however many colors
you need you know in that sort of
environment so i'm just making the point
that the sme story is a big one
uh and we need to work on it in all
directions
we just started recently a credit
guarantee scheme
uh but credit is not everything it is
credit plus
great thanks governor i've got another
question from alio paul um
who starts off saying kenya's work on
fintech is truly impressive thanks ali
uh the governor will take full credit
for it don't worry
he asks being the cradle of fintech he's
curious about what lessons you might
have the central bank
policy of having a mature fintech
environment
you you touch on the financial stability
angle
are there any specific lessons for the
transmission of monetary policy that you
think about
okay wow difficult question
i mean generally i think depending on
the wagons that you put there
you'll have different let's say risks on
transmission on monetary policy
um obviously if it is lending then
this has a significant impact and we've
had to do some work
as a matter of fact for you to know we
are improving our monetary policy
framework
um precisely because of reasons such as
this
because now money mobile money is very
important
um it is no longer just something that
is uh
in the corner somewhere lending etc and
therefore
you need to incorporate that when you're
thinking
or designing a policy um so
is that but i think that is only one
angle
the other elements depending on the
organs as i said if you are
into savings by the way remind me of
need to tell them about our savings
product but uh
savings product then obviously
transmission will be somewhat different
um but it will still be there my point
is
you need to think through it um step by
step
and sort of there's no shortcut um
you have to do this sort of the brute
force sort of step by step
uh checking of how this uh i
this monetary policy is being
transmitted through
all the channels and indeed through all
the products that are there
but in terms of central bank policy more
generally
uh i don't think the biggest issue for
me for this product
is on monitor the risk i don't think it
is on monetary policy i think the
biggest risk is more on
financial stability and that is an
important element
and and i think here is where you need
to be more on top
in terms of monitoring
monitoring getting data is so
very important this is one of the
reasons why we we are much further ahead
on data
and we want to make sure that we have
sort of a you know
a data lake that you can slice and dice
any whichever way you know
um and uh and i think in that sense then
you can see the problem before it comes
over the
you know over the horizon as it were
yeah you can already begin to see the
elements of that so
that is there and then the other thing
uh the last point on this
is um the law needs to change
i mean a lot of us think that you have a
law and it is static
actually in this area because it's very
dynamic the law needs to be
much more malleable and
and so how you craft it
the way you write the law well that is
that's one issue
but i think also appreciating that uh
you do need to go to the law and amend
it and
tweak it in whichever way and maybe it
is in the law
directly it's also other things like the
prudential guidelines
um when they come out you need to i mean
writing this quickly and changing them
as needed so those are the directions i
would probably
put out for i mean to think in terms of
central bank policy yeah it's related to
one of the questions in the chat i'm not
going to ask the question directly but
it's about kind of
how do you think about big data that's
also coming from the telcos
and is there a piece of that that gets
regulated by you guys
for use in credit scoring etc like you
said and
how do you think of that data piece i
know we have a data bill
um that imposes significant
restrictions on the use of data but you
know we're going to a world where
you know a lot about people from their
phones and as people use smartphones
you learn even more right the digital
lending apps can see facebook can see
your call records can see your text
message content
you know so we're getting to the point
where some people have access to a lot
of
data is you know do you think of how you
regulate that
or is that up to uh the communications
commission and
how do you see that regulation process
because it fits into the credit banking
system somewhat
yeah a good question i think we are we
are definitely involved in it
uh let's start there but i think it
isn't so much who is involved in it
uh that is important i think it is the
attitude that
with which are the prisms that you view
the data that is available whatever it
is
i think first and foremost the data
belongs to the consumer
it does not belong to the telco it does
not belong to the
um let's say the the bank that is
working
with the uh with the individual
telco or whatever else it is and
therefore
to use that to use the data you do need
to uh to provide them with um
i mean you need to do it with a complete
understanding of the
of the consumer and here is where i
think i and
sorry to uh to put it this way but i
think we'll all understand it
you know you are your iphone or whatever
it updates
uh to a new operating system right 13
points whatever
i don't know now it's 13 or whatever it
is i don't actually know either
it is the this is a this is exactly my
point
so for me at least that updates i leave
it
in the you know in the evening that's
when it will update
and then in the morning it will ask me
uh do you want to
push this to agree on the conditions
and uh yes or no i mean you know so well
and they know that i cannot say no i
just push yes and move on
it's not informed so this informed
consent is very important
um it has to be brought down to the
level
of the consumer and also the consumer
needs to be
given many opportunities to
in a sense withdraw from all this sort
of and get
and all the data is removed and and it
has to be
it's hard work sure it's hard work but
it is important to be uh to do all there
is to protect
the consumer i think what has happened
now and this is the problem of some of
the digital lenders
uh that we are dealing with is they
when you join they will ask you well you
know can
we would like to use your your
contacts right your list of contacts and
then you say yes and you move on right
yeah and what happens uh they haven't
told you how they're gonna use it
um but what happens is when you don't uh
repay they will call people
on your contacts list i mean just think
of that you know your
uh your family your boss um
and uh your your priest back in the
rural area and the
everybody's been told listen you know
so-and-so hasn't
and this is your your brother you you
know he hasn't paid up you know you need
to do something
so i'm just making the point that that
is not informed consent
so i use that example a lot
saying also i think governor the
difference is if apple had something
really bad in the terms and conditions
someone would have found it and there
would have been
a process around uproar to solve it
right that's
less so in this case i think the
institutions don't function quite the
same way
right but of here i disagree with you i
don't think
something you disagree yeah i mean i i
there was this uh anyway i saw my phone
someone would have read it to you but
when they introduced uh something when
was it back in 2019
and in a sense uh it was any it wasn't
informed consent let's just be honest
yeah i think this is going to be a big
issue is how we think about
who's who owns data and how you give
consent to use that data and for what
and as we do digital identification as
well with the houdouma number and things
like that and start to connect it to
things i think this is going to become
really important
uh from both a consumer like you said a
consumer information perspective but
also a regulatory perspective
and i think that's the to be honest this
is where i'm
i have um well we've been a bit
concerned about the large telcos
um if i may just uh have a segway into
that
because in a sense there is a bit of a
monopolistic uh behavior as they try and
sort of grab
uh data there's a lot of data in the
payment space
a lot of data in the payment space about
people
etc etc and so when you get a large talk
of getting into the payments
and not just a large telco i'm just
talking of you know
the big tech you know generally um we
need to be careful
i mean and this is one of the things
that in my mind uh
when you think of uh some of the large
big techs around the world you know sort
of
making inroads into africa i think the
first question is what are they going to
do with the data
and i think in some sense they also know
that
there's a fast move advantage so once
they grab
some of this data um it'll be very
difficult to
you know to get it out of their hands
you know and
so i think we need to be careful about
it we have a responsibility
as regulators um to make sure that
the people that we are responsible for
um
do not fall in those sort of
problems in our jurisdictions
great i think we're close to running out
of time
so um i think we should
wrap up there's a couple minutes just
two minutes left governor so let me uh
take the opportunity to thank everybody
who's attended and thank you for being
here
sorry we didn't get to all the q a um
but
uh i really want to thank you governor
for being with us today and kicking off
our
celebrations of the growth center and
the id program uh
and making time i know it's evening in
nairobi and just having a conversation
with us
which is way more fun than than than
speaking i think and so for at least for
me it is
um i hope it was for you too but we'd
really we're really grateful for your
time
and and for you being here today i don't
know tony if you want to add anything
thank you that was great really
interesting the
q a format was uh quite useful and i i
learned a bunch of things i didn't know
about
how money and finance is working kenny i
knew a few things but it's quite
interesting you're kind of on the
forefront there
i think we can learn a lot from that
from what's going on there
so um you know i think it was a great
event um
very much enjoyed uh you both
participating
and and i'll just close with saying you
know this just shows
um the extent to which i think yale is
a center for development economics and
this kind of conversation happening here
is it
is an illustration of that and um
and let me congratulate again the id
program on 65 years of existence it's
one of the premier programs of its kind
in the world so this
this event was great in showcasing all
those um all that success with that
program
so thank you thank you tony thank you
thank you tony
thank you tonight i'm gonna hopefully
see you in nairobi soon
yeah we hope so uh looking forward to
seeing you
yes sir thank you for being here we
really appreciate it okay
all the best goodbye to the participants
thank you
you